To illustrate the need for
malware analysis and
the challenges associated with it,
let's consider one of the common malware
obfuscation techniques, packing.
Packing refers to the process
of compressing and
encrypting part of
an executable program.
The result of packing is that part of
the executable program now becomes data,
instead of an instruction set, and,
in order to execute that part of the
program that has been packed in runtime,
we must reverse it back
from data to insertion set.
That is, we now must include in the
executable program some code that will
reverse this packing process,
and this is called the unpacking.
To give an illustrated example,
we have the original program,
Program A here, and you see that
the program contains instruction sets.
With a packing tool, that includes
compression and encryption and so on.
The result of packing is that
part of the program, meaning,
part of the instruction set,
now becomes data.
We observed that the packing
result looks random,
meaning the data here looks random.
This is because it is encrypted
with a randomly generated key
each time the packing program
is run on a malware program.
That is, even for
the same malware program, each packed
instance would look different, and,
therefore, a signature-based approach
is not effective in detecting
the packed malware.
Now you say this pack
program will include
code that try to unpack the packed part.
Can we use the unpacking code
as signature to detect malware?
The answer's no.
The reason is that legitimate
programs may also include packing in
order to hide certain logic and data,
for example, for copyright protection.
That is, some legitimate programs
also have unpacking code.
It will unpack some part
of the program in runtime.
Therefore we cannot use the unpacking
code as signature to detect malware.